I think there's a line in my college
application essay that goes, "If math and
science hadn't found me, my mother always
says I'd be a Broadway star."
The MTA Playwrights Lab is the sort of first
ever of its kind here at MIT,
a collaboration between playwriting
students and theatre professionals. So I
took eight playwrights into my
playwrights workshop this spring and
each of those eight writers is getting
a professional staged reading this
weekend as part of the Lab.
Seeing the
process of a play going from an idea to
something that might be executable to
something that might be publishable
has been a great experience.
I could become a Galactic Arboriterator, or start a business.
How are you gonna become an arbitrator when you can't even say the word?
I'll learn.
The first
two readings, both of them sold out, so we
had over fifty students here in the
audience, and it's mostly students, so
it's exciting that a lot of young MIT kids
who have probably never seen a staged
reading before, come in here to support
their fellow students' works.
And being inspired by science, because my play, as
you just saw, is like science fiction, being
inspired by science and, like, wanting so
much from the world and always
questioning, like , as we technologically
advance so much, are we, like, morally
advancing, are we doing anything that's
like --- are we on par with the things that we're creating?
Is it not simpler and easier to get your money another way?
Well, yes, but you were opposed to my previous plan.
And what makes you think I won't be opposed to this one?
Because I expect the money from Port Saba to sing to you. Ooh yes, look at that...
The rules of storytelling, which is
really what playwrights are, you know,
essentially learning, is really going to
be useful whether or not it's about
making a presentation or writing an
essay or building a website. I think that,
like, whatever you're doing, you're kind
of telling a story in some way, and so if
you learn how stories are made, and you
learn what some of the sort of
interlocking parts of stories are, even
if you're just learning the rules so as
to break them, I think it's kind of good
to sort of think about what you're doing
as an act of storytelling.